>>> WE'RE BACK WITH A CNN
EXCLUSIVE.
SOURCES SAY THAT DONALD TRUMP'S
LEGAL TEAM IS IN TALKS WITH KEY
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS IN
AN EFFORT TO SHIELD
CONVERSATIONS TRUMP HAD WHILE
PRESIDENT.
THESE ARE THE FIRST SIGN OF
DIRECT COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
TRUMP'S TEAM AND THE FEDERAL
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATORS WHO MAY
INVESTIGATE HIM ABOUT HIS
JANUARY 6th ACTIONS.
CNN SENIOR CRIME AND JUSTICE
REPORTER KAITLIN PO LANCE WITH
THIS EXCLUSIVE REPORTING.
HOW SIGNIFICANT ARE THESE
CONVERSATIONS?
>> THIS IS SIGNIFICANT.
EVERYTHING WE ARE SEEING IS THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT CIRCLING
AROUND DONALD TRUMP, HIS WEST
WING, EVEN HIS STATEMENTS MADE
ON JANUARY 6th, AND SOURCES
TODAY ARE CONFIRMING THAT THERE
IS DIRECT COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
LAWYERS REPRESENTING DONALD
TRUMP.
AND SO THIS DEVELOPMENT IS NOT
JUST ANY TYPE OF COMMUNICATIONS.
IT'S REALLY BUILDING ON A STORY
THAT HAS BEEN UNFOLDING THE PAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS WHERE THERE WERE
PEOPLE FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT BROUGHT BEFORE
THE FEDERAL GRAND JURY IN
WASHINGTON TESTIFYING ABOUT WHAT
THEY WERE HEARING IN THE WEST
WING ON JANUARY 6th AND THEN
PEOPLE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNCIL'S OFFICE WERE RECEIVING
SUBPOENAS TO GO TO THE GRAND
JURY.
THAT TEES UP THIS POSSIBLE
PRIVILEGE FIGHT OVER EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, WHAT TRUMP WAS
SAYING, HAPPENING THEN, AND THAT
LEADS TO THESE CONVERSATIONS.
THAT'S WHAT THE CONVERSATIONS
ARE ABOUT, AND TRUMP'S TEAM IS
MAINTAINING THAT DONALD TRUMP
HAS THE ABILITY TO ASSERT
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE AND
DEFINITELY PROTECT THE THINGS
THAT HE BELIEVES SHOULD BE
SECRET ABOUT HIS PRESIDENCY.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ON THEIR
END, THEY HAVE A LOT OF HISTORY
ON THEIR SIDE POTENTIALLY GIVING
THEM ACCESS TO THAT.
THEY MAY HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
COURT.
>> YOU ARE LEARNING THAT TRUMP
HAS BEEN BRIEFED ON ALL OF THIS.
HOW IS THE TEAM HANDLING THIS
INTERNALLY?
>> WELL, FROM WHAT WE KNOW, THEY
HAVE BEEN WARNING HIM THERE ARE
POSSIBLE INDICTMENTS COMING IN
THE JANUARY 6th INVESTIGATION
AROUND HIM AND THEY ARE
DISCUSSING DEFENSE STRATEGIES AT
LEAST TWICE WITH HIM.
HE HAS BEEN ASKING HIM, ASKING
HIS LAWYERS AND OTHERS IF THEY
THINK THAT HE WILL BE CHARGED.
OF COURSE, THIS IS TRUMP BEING
TRUMP.
OUR SOURCES SAY HE SEEMS TO BE
SKEPTICAL THAT HE WILL POSSIBLY
BE CHARGED.
AT TIMES, HE DOESN'T APPEAR TO
BE LISTENING TO WHAT HIS
ADVISORS ARE TELLING HIM.
>> THAT SOUNDS LIKE TRUMP.
HE HAS BEEN WARNED ABOUT HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
SO HIS ADVISORS ARE TELLING HIM,
IT MIGHT THE TIME TO BACK OFF
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH SOME
OF THE PEOPLE GETTING CAUGHT OR
PARTICIPATING IN THE JANUARY 6th
PROBES ON THE HILL.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, THAT
INCLUDES MARK MEADOWS, HIS
FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, THIS PERSON WHO
BECAME CENTRAL IN WHAT THE HOUSE
WAS INVESTIGATING AND
POTENTIALLY COULD BE CENTRAL IN
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT PROBE AS
WELL.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT HE WAS
ADVISED, TRUMP WAS ADVISED TO
CUT TIES WITH MEADOWS.
THAT HASN'T ACTUALLY FULLY
HAPPENED.
AND THIS POSSIBILITY THAT
MEADOWS COULD BECOME MORE
CENTRAL IN THE CRIMINAL PROBE,
WE HAVEN'T SEEN A LOT OF THAT
EVIDENCE YET AS FAR AS WHAT WE
ARE LEARNING WITH THIS GRAND
JURY ACTIVITY, BUT WHEN ASKED
ABOUT IT, WE ASKED MEADOWS'
ATTORNEY WHEN HE THOUGHT, AND
HIS RESPONSE WAS, ALL IS IDL